i do think times two should be reserved
for chilly tutorials that take two
[ __ ]
yeah two lights totally agree with you i
totally agree with you i i don't trust
anyone
who opens up a tutorial and doesn't
immediately skip to two minutes in like
oh yeah like there's so many [ __ ]
channels that are like tutorials like
yo what's up guys i'm like you should
not youtubers should who do tutorials
should not be allowed to do intros yeah
like
you should basically just telling me
give me the information [ __ ]
get right into it dude like yo what's up
guys i'm uploading daily content okay
okay okay okay
next week i'm live streaming i'm gonna
be talking about and it's i remember
i remember the other day because i was
trying to like fix something with my cam
link right
and i was like okay i need to figure out
some issues with cam link and there was
this video which was like you know
five issues with cam link and how to fix
it it was like a 10 minute video i'm
like all right like maybe they're gonna
go like two minutes it doesn't need to
be ten minutes
and i'm like dude this dude like legit
like swear to god for the first six
minutes he was just plugging all this
[ __ ] and like trying to add like jokes
and stuff and he's like all right let's
get into the meat of the video and i'm
like there's only four minutes left how
are you going to talk about five
problems
and how to solve them in four minutes
oh my god dude you know you know it's a
big issue when even like because you you
can google this stuff and
google will show you the video results
yeah and it'll literally skip to the
point where it
thinks that the tutorial actually starts
which is like if google is automating
this why do people think that anyone
else is going to [ __ ] watch it i
remember like 2010 when it was like
video game like oh where is this thing
or how to do this thing yeah
always watch a video the video will show
you exactly how to do it and we'll jump
right into it but now it's going like no
commentary just yeah now it's going like
backwards where i'm like i guess i'll
click the forum first and
see if i can get the information in 10
seconds yeah so i'm going to click on
this 20 minute video and [ __ ]
you know is it the same operating system
[ __ ] yeah it's like
it's like i don't care about your
gambling jokes all right just just tell
me how to fix my [ __ ] cam link
please speaking of all the times that
i've had like attack issue
and it's some guy with like the thickest
accent like trying to explain i'm like
okay [ __ ] what is he saying
uh times two and he's like literally
swallowing the microphone as well see
like even at times two speeds like i
can't i can't
and you have to go down to the comments
to like see if someone's like sit like
paraphrase it in some way
you know what hey youtube has started
doing a thing where
you can i mean they've done it for a
while but if you're a foreign channel so
i could put like french titles
yeah right so there was this one where
it was a guide and i clicked on it and
i'm pretty sure it was like an indian
guide fully in like
indian all right and i was like what the
[ __ ] why is the title in english
right yeah it's like how to fix your
android five problem i was like sick
that's exactly what i want i click on it
and he starts talking in here i'm like
what the [ __ ]
and like there was no subtitles or
anything right yeah who why
why would you yeah because it like auto
translates the titles right but you have
to approve that i think
yeah right no but like i've i've done
that before with like because i watch
like a lot of like japanese videos as
well with like japanese titles
and for some reason every now and then
there's a video where
if i search for it it's displayed in
japanese but the moment i click on it
the title turns to english
yeah is it the dude who makes the knives
out of [ __ ] that one too but also
there's like a bunch of just like i've
like a lot of like youtuber clips for
example like are written in japanese in
the search bar
but then the moment i click it it turns
to english yeah i've noticed that as
well and i feel like why
yeah i don't know which is why i feel
like youtube getting rid of closed
captions is like
the biggest [ __ ] mistake i don't know
why they're doing it they're like 0.5
people use them whatever i was like
that's still 0.5 percent of how many
[ __ ] millions
the entire youtube community is crying
right now yeah right
how about we make it worse
that feature that allows me to
conveniently change subtitles depending
on which language
wow that would be stupid man let's get
rid of that [ __ ] help
[ __ ] youtube's so dumb sometimes
jesus [ __ ] christ
i can't believe it stop changing youtube
stop
stop changing for the worse stop
changing like they're like how about we
do the 50th
logo redesign to more minimalism the
color red is now our logo
but but let's take out all the good
features and it's like oh okay i guess
yeah jesus they take so many l's
remember they did the uh
like what was that what was the funniest
one the youtube hero stream of that one
oh my god what was that again it's like
where like they were gonna like make
mods basically out of like youtube users
where they could like oh i remember i
don't even remember that
it was a [ __ ] mess it was so funny
thank god